we have this clip from the Samsung
Galaxy s24 Ultra commercial and I want
to explain to you why this is the
apocalypse this this is Skynet it's been
a good run Humanity it's over I can't
wait to get one and uh I ordered one
myself U mine's going to be here at the
end of the month did you order one mine
will be here at the end of the month I'm
very excited for it but uh what I'm
talking about is their AI phone app
which incorporates intrinsic Photoshop
capabilities but also can generate
portions of an image that don't exist
for artistic value meaning they showed
in one demo when a photo was taken at an
angle of a guy you can rotate it but
then the edges are cut off and
autogenerate the edges using artificial
intelligence that will generate what it
appears it may be this means photos are
going to be created we're Beyond filters
okay filban I know Photoshop exists but
Photoshop is a is is a rare thing
and we question when these when fake
photos are made on average if someone
takes a picture on their phone it's a
real picture with the Advent of the s24
and it's not just the s24 Apple the
iPhone is doing this too but we are in
this era now the phone the pictures that
are stored on people's phones are all
going to be Fabrications and imitations
of reality meaning we are no longer
recording what's really going on we are
manufacturing fake records of of of
events so in this clip let me play this
clip for you so you can see exactly what
he's talking about photos in your
gallery then again this blue three star
button to activate Galaxy AI when you're
in this mode here are a few things you
can look at that he just this is great
I'm buying the phone by the way right he
Taps the guy who's in it and removes him
the first is you can tap or Draw around
anything you want the interesting thing
is he clicks generate right it's buil
for when you want to remove unwanted
people or objects from the background as
you can see here okay he removes the guy
outright and what's behind him nothing
the AI created a a fake image the reason
why this is so freaky this is exactly
what I've been warning about as to how
AI will destroy things the example I've
given Donald Trump speaking at that
press conference after uh um uh was it
charl charlott's uh Charlottesville
Charlottesville there you go wow I can't
believe forgot the name of the city and
he says I am not talking about the white
nationalists and the neonazis because
they should be condemned totally the
left lied Biden lied they claimed he
said you know verifying people referring
to them when he said he wasn't the full
cont TT with altering very slightly
using deep fake technology you change
Trump from saying they should be
condemned totally to some should be
condemned totally and that alters the
context massively and will be impossible
to track so the left will share the
video of trump saying some should be
condemned totally and they'll go wow he
actually thought others there were nice
he didn't say all of them and the right
will point out no no no he said they
should be he referring to all of them
say no here's our video here's your
video there will be two videos with only
one word changed what we're going to see
here now is how about this Donald Trump
is at a rally and he's shaking hands
with a guy and then someone takes a
picture of it on their phone and just
drags Trump over shaking hands with a
different guy and that other guy happens
to be a prominent white nationalist
Trump doesn't know was standing in the
background M these are the kinds of
things we'll start to see that are
shocking and scary but I think the
bigger picture here is outside of those
rare occurrences is that every photo you
see in Instagram filters are already
changing what women and and men look
like and it's causing problems in
people's brains young girls are getting
crazy plastic surgery I read an article
today about a guy who got bone
lengthening surgery and it's causing him
such pain that he can't sleep anymore
because he's like I need to be tall you
know that's what the internet says 4
inches he went from five 58 to six feet
gosh right and so what's going to happen
now is these photos that are going to be
posted all over the place are basically
fake in their entirety so in this video
he removes the guy from the picture and
then moves his this other guy over that
never happened and you know another
thing is like there's people already are
so uh like confirmation bias is such a
massive problem that if you just show
people pictures that are you know
doctored and they already want to you
know hate whoever it may be a picture of
that you're you know showing them
they're already geared to to believe
negative things about a person if they
don't like him so if you show a picture
that's you know post truth reality man
you know it's it's it's going to be real
tough to get people you know to to to
navigate do you guys remember there was
this uh this like e girl or whatever
this Asian woman and it was like a young
woman making a bunch of money and then
at one point she moved and the filter
missed and it she turned into an old
lady and then back and everyone went
whoa she's an old lady the whole time
pretending to be like an 18-year-old
girl to make money that's where we're
going I think that the older generation
is going to be more susceptible to it
people that were raised like in the
TV picture era that still like
communicate by sending pictures and not
video they don't use video chat as much
like the young people might be more on
guard to this kind of stuff older so
older people still watch CNN and Fox
News and cable TV because that's the
world they grew up in and they have
peers when they go to events they see
other people like them who they will
talk to and they have a shared reality
what's going to happen with this is
older people are going this is the crazy
thing it's going to create an amalgam
reality of a a unified social system so
man this is so it's so crazy to break
down when I worked for vice I kept
saying things like why aren't we
investing in social media I know that
Vice is big on social media but why are
they so obsessed with TV and documentary
it's because Shane Smith the CEO was in
his
mid-40s and what was big to the Gen xers
was cable TV and he was only like the
Internet is just something that helped
us launch I was a younger guy and my
whole world was the internet and I was
like I don't understand why they're
doing this old stuff that no one cares
about it's because when the CEO went to
board meetings and when he went to
investors the only thing they cared
about was TV so in his world TV was
everything the internet was something
ancillary for me I didn't know anybody
who cared about tv nobody watched it
everybody was on the internet with this
and social media and fabricated reality
you're going to have people who are and
we're already seeing this they're going
to be like this is exactly what's
happening right now a 40 y old woman
wanting to fit in online with the
average age and trying to be 20 they're
going to filter everything that that's
why you're going to see a a 60-year-old
woman running filters to appear like
she's 20 I'm seeing like kids in the
future in the next 10 15 years when they
get a picture sent by one of their
friends the first question I'll ask is
what did you doctor with your AI when
they see the picture they won't even
they'll know that that's part of it
whereas people that are 60 and 70 are
from the age of Polaroids where a
picture was what it was it was real and
so they'll be like they'll just look at
it and they won't even question there
there's already really funny videos of
like uh playing GTA for old people and
the old people think it's real cuz they
don't know what these things are they're
watching a video of a car like Chase and
then flip over and the graphics are so
amazing and their eyes aren't so good
that they're like oh and they all the
young people are laughing like it's a
video game yeah I wonder how the fact
Checkers are going to deal with this you
know because obviously we know some of
them are biased But ultimately when
things are being posted online
especially during election years how do
they vet that information how do they
see if a photo is legit this is an
opportunity for fact cheers yes this is
this is an opportunity to shape the
facts the way they see deep take deep
deep fake uh recognition software has
got to be like it's the new lock on your
door like for your brain you've got to
know if something's been deep faked
we've already tried this with there
there's already apps that do deep fake
detection and they've been wrong on a
lot of issues on on a lot of images uh
the the the photos coming out of Israel
that people are getting different
results it was saying it was fake or it
wasn't fake and nobody everyone's like
this is a really good example it was the
remains of a baby and the left were all
saying it was fake yeah and the right
was all saying it's real and what would
happen is people on the left would run
through their air DET air deep fake
detection it would say it's a fake photo
and they' go aha proof and then people
on the right would be like I checked
this and it's saying it's it's a real
photo so you you choose reality is your
choice the evidence is meaningless yep
and eventually people are just going to
start fighting each other because
they're going to be like I don't
understand I saw the video of trump
kicking that dog and someone else is
going to be like he was kicking the dog
he was pushing it out of the way of of a
coming truck it's going to be like
insert reality that's current I mean
that currently goes on there's the the
people that were you know argue about
what they saw with with um oh Jim aosta
Jim
aosta when uh he was he had the
microphone in his hand fight over M it
was funny to see these pets be like the
White House Aid tried to rip the mic
from him and my point was like so what
even if she did try to take the mic from
him it's not his mic why was he holding
on to it but I thought it was fairly
obvious that he jerked his hand back
from her mhm she went to grab it and
then he pulls his hand back like I think
what happened was he was tensing up
trying to stop her from taking it and
when she took it it he pulled his hand
back yeah and people look at the Kyle
writtenhouse footage all that footage
and they still see different things and
it's not a surprise this isn't anything
new and yeah it's only going to get
worse and and more confusing and more
difficult and the crazy thing is um
with the written housee case we already
saw the attempted use of AI generated
imagery imagery to convict someone when
they zoomed in and said see there you
can see it and then the judge didn't
understand Zoom isn't a thing you can't
zoom in you can't create pixels so the
phone manufactures what it thinks will
be there it is it is an artificial
intelligence generating the image as you
zoom in it is not real but people don't
know that yeah derck shavin learned the
hard way over the video that went viral
looks like his his knee is on you know
George Floyd's neck and then ultimately
a different angle makes it appear like
it's not exactly on his neck it was on
his upper back or something yeah yeah I
think it was over more towards the
shoulder blade area is what it kind of
looks like from a different angle
doesn't look like it was what politics I
mean that that I think that case
outright the video doesn't even matter
the fact that the guy who was you know
standing nearby holding an Angry Crowd
back is going to prison like I think
with Amed ARB and George Floyd the it is
actually quite simple if you cause
problems for the system we will discard
you yeah that's it
yeah that's where we're at and they have
sadly yeah but uh I suppose now we will
go to super chats so if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.net things and I know people are
already chatting saying Tim said before
that you don't need money to do these
things and that if you need the money
like do not misconstrue what I am saying
what I'm saying is you can get started
on your own but ain't nobody's trying to
make the argument that you can run a 42
person staff uh media operation without
support of members and advertisers my
point is that you build up to that point
from the ground up no one is going to
come to you and say I will give you a
million dollar per month to run a media
company unless you already have done so
know how to do so and can build it so if
you were saying I could do it if only I
had the money right my point is the
average person who's trying to build up
a successful business you need to start
from the ground up and and make it work
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 P.M
and become a member over at
timcast.net elusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next
time